Abby came and shaking her head no, but I love droughts. Difference of opinion.
Thank you. We will now transition from parks and recreation to
Houston Police department. At this time, I would welcome
Chief Fender and Miss Rhonda. Smith, the CFO
of Houston Police Department, along with Chief
Satterwhite. Chief Slinkert. And I thought I saw Chief
Jones as well. So good to see everybody.
And of course, Ms. Rhonda Smith, the CFO. Chief,
I saw you in DC. You look good. How was that plane trip?
Oh, you're a smart man. Yeah.
Good to see you.
I just want to thank each and every council
member for such support. It means a lot
having the opportunity to talk to chiefs all around the nation
and to have the support from the Horseshoe. It means a lot,
but we'll jump right into it.
Chief Troy Finner. And on behalf of the Houston Police Department,
I appreciate the opportunity to submit the HPD's
proposed budget budget for FY 2023.
Let me first say how proud I am to be the police
chief in this great city with this great department.
The benefit of the burian audience.
HPD is the largest agency in the state of Texas,
fourth largest in the nation. We have over
I'm sorry, the fifth largest in the nation. We have over 6100,
both classified and civilian employees.
Before moving forward, I'd like to acknowledge the men and women of the Houston Police
Department, but especially the executive staff and the budget
and finance staff who has worked so diligently to prepare
this presentation. This year began and
has been very challenging for us, as around the
nation, we lost some of our own family members. But in
Houston and Harris County, there was a total of six.
Now, last week, seven line of duty deaths.
We also faced the challenge of increasing
crime. At the beginning of the year, especially,
my top priority is to address those.
The trends of increasing crime was to reduce
the violent crime, enhance technology,
and also improve the staffing.
Just want to say the One
Safe Houston initiative has been successful. We've been doing an
excellent job looking at the numbers. Every week
those numbers have been going down, and we've seen a reduction
in violent crime on a weekly basis. So, again,
I want to thank the mayor, I want to thank City Council for
the additional opera rescue funding and
fighting crime and reducing some of that crime
and improving the quality of life. I want to hit on
one stat before we move forward.
In January, as compared to the previous
year, our homicide numbers were over 70%.
Today it's 7%. And that is
a direct result of good policing,
but also everybody working together,
our citizens and the criminal justice system coming together.
Technology. We have secured the following major technology milestones.
Body warrant camera upgrades will allow us
to purchase the next well, 300 I'm sorry,
3500 next generation body worn cameras.
The HPD data center locate relocation.
We completely moved the HPD primary data center
to a shared space within the city data center.
We've moved over 300 servers.
We've implemented Shot spotters not only in the Southeast,
but also in the North Division. Now,
I'm sorry, our RMS system, we're in a quiet period,
but we have an RFP out.
That's all I'm going to say about that. But it will assist
us in our fight of violent crime.
We want to make our real time crime center a true strategic
decision support system. The expansion
of automated license plate readers in
high crime areas and also cameras. So we're looking,
and I want to thank certain council members for funding
that. It's something that we want to
move around the city, but it's not just the responsibility of
the city and taxpayers. We want to get everybody on board on that.
We also, in terms of staffing, we have to
continue to fund the five academy classes
each year.
Also want to thank council for
working on city audience, for the Cadillac converter audience,
the noise audits audits. And also the
exterior security video camera audit audits.
And also the county for passing the
10% bond for defendants charged with violent crime.
The presentation will begin with an overview of organizational
structure. For the sake of time, I will move through these slides quickly
and answer any questions at the end. Next slide.
This slide shows a current organization structure.
Next slide.
This slide is basically the addition of the
executive assistant Chief I'm sorry, the Executive chief, chief Slinker,
which we added that new position at the beginning of my administration.
Next slide. This is
the office of the police, of the Chief of Police.
Everything that's up under my command. Next slide.
This slide, it looks at investigations and special operations.
It's under Chief Jones.
And the next slide is patrol operations on the chief satellite.
Next slide, please. This is a special fund.
In addition to our general funds, our organization includes
operations and special funds. These are funds that are restricted.
The money is restricted for restricted use. I meant to say Ms.
Smith will go into further detail here just shortly.
Next slide. Want to look at the
breakdown of gender of our agency. The significant thing about
this slide is for cities of over 1 million
in population I'm sorry,
we move it. One more slide. One more.
Thank you.
For cities over 1 million in population.
And the police departments have 17% female.
HPD is also at 17%. For the civilian,
that's for classified. For the civilians,
we're at 68% as compared to the national average of
66%.
HPD is one of the most diverse law enforcement agencies
in the nation. We're a majority I'm sorry. Next slide. Go to it.
HPD is one of the most diverse agencies in
the nation. We are a majority minority police department
with 78.9% of the civilians
are minority, 60.9% of classified.
A closer breakdown of it looking at the classified side,
39% Caucasian,
31% Hispanic or Latino,
21% African American and
8% Asian. For the civilian workforce,
we have 45% African American,
21% White, 25% Latino
Hispanic and then 8% Asian.
The department programming. I always like to state our
mission statement. Mission statement is to hang the quality of life
in the city of Houston by working
cooperatively with the public within the framework work of
the US constitution to enforce laws, preserve the peace,
reduce fear, and provide a safe environment.
Next slide.
Reducing violent crime is one of the mayor's
highest priorities, and we have made great strides in accomplishing
the goal. Despite financial challenges and staffing,
some of the core duties prevent
crime, respond to calls for service, conduct investigations,
arrest individuals suspected of committing crimes,
coordinate with Homeland Security activities, protect lives and property
during mass gathering and special events, and also enforcing
traffic. Next slide.
Department program continues statutory requirements of
delivery of services. The Texas Code of Criminal
Procedure and the city ordinance. Chapter 34, article two,
defines the duties of the Houston Police Department.
Recently, our team published
a five year strategic plan listing five key
organizational priorities. One was public safety.
Building community trust was two. Three was professional development.
Four was Operational Excellence
and five was productivity. This budget proposal
funding request for key initiatives discussed in
this plan, which are first ePROs
and that is employment programs for retired officers.
42 individuals will come back as retired officers
and it will give us immediate assistance in investigations and
other administrative duties. Five cadet classes budgeted
for 75 per class. A gun intelligence
center. We're working with Atl to implement
a robust gun intelligence center. And also
cell phones. Continued cell phones for each classified
officer previously. This is funded by the
Cares Act. I would
like to now ask Ms. Smith, our Chief Financial Officer,
to provide an overview of the 2023 proposed
budget. Thank you. Thank you,
Chief. Good morning everyone.
My name is Rhonda. Smith, as the chief has said.
And I am the deputy director for the Houston Police Department.
And I echo Chief Sinner's sentiment
in terms of working with such a great crew. And so I
want to take just a minute point of privilege to talk about the Office of
Budget and Finance who've been working tirelessly throughout the year
and particularly now for the budget presentation. So I'm
going to ask them just to stand so I can acknowledge them.
So we're always behind the scenes, so they are a little shy,
but thank you. So as we move forward,
this first slide is the revenue by fund. First, I'd like to just say
that the police department operates under six
funds. The primary fund is the general fund, which makes up about 97%
of our operations. The other funds are special funds. And so each fund
has a revenue component. And this is what you see here on this slide.
So for the first item, general fund and I'll be
speaking from the column that's titled Fiscal Year 23 proposed Budget
for the General Fund. The proposed revenue
anticipated is $43.5 million.
Now, it's revenue, but it's actually a reimbursement.
84% of that is the reimbursement that we receive from
the airport systems. So we provide those services for intercontinental
hobby and the Ellington field. The next
item is our police special services fund.
This is a collection of special funds for restricted use.
For example, all of the training that we do that is provided
by the state flows through this fund,
reimbursement for what's called MoUs, or Memorandum
of Understanding, which we have with other agencies,
flow through this fund and funding for our combat against
human trafficking, as well as cost recovery services and
special funds and special events.
We anticipate that that budget would be 7.9 million.
And our next item, our special fund is auto dealers.
And for revenue for that one, we are anticipating 8.5
budgeted for the auto dealers. And of course,
with auto dealers, it's a standalone fund.
And this fund is responsible for regulating automotive businesses,
auto salespersons, storage lots, and towing industry.
So the revenue we receive primarily is coming from fees that we
charge in servicing that process.
Our next item is child safety fund. And that's clearly just a
flow through. Just for by way of background, in 1991,
the state legislature required that any population over 850,000
should fund it. And we fund it through assessing certain
fees on municipal fines. And so
what we get, we pass back through. And if we don't get
enough, then there's no money else, no other way
to get the funding. And so that's what that child safety fund is.
And of course, asset forfeiture. So under asset forfeiture.
The one thing I'll say, and I know my stuff is looking at me because
we cannot budget for asset forfeiture
because it's on a case by case basis other than the state
allows us to do some budgeting. But I will say that typically right
now, we're budgeting $2 million, which is, if you look in the history,
it's a little lower than anticipated. But what has happened is
that we are taking the same impact everyone else is with
COVID and the court systems, because in order to receive these
funds, it has to flow through the court system.
So we're hoping that in time that we will be back
on chart. And lastly is the Forensic
Transition fund. And that Forensic Transition Fund that shows 373,000,000
is really just a flow through because back
in 2014, I believe we transitioned the
operations of the Forensic Fund to the local government
corporation. But we kept the funding, we kept the actual
individuals that were associated with HPD
in our funding. So we received reimbursement.
So the good news is it's doing what it's supposed to. It was
a transition. It started with probably more than 20. Now we only have three
staff left. So we anticipate over the next several years that that
will move down. So what we have in total is $65
million for revenue. Next slide,
please. So this
slide just highlights some of the reasons why there's a difference
from year to year and the comparison is with the estimated
revenue compared to the budget. So for General Fund we're showing a $1.4
million increase. As I mentioned before, 84% of the
General Fund revenue has to do with our services to the police,
of services to the airport system. So of course a lot of the
increase has to do with the contractual obligations.
In reference to the 4% increase for police
and the 3% for civilian. The one thing
I will highlight that the one new add on
is seven positions anticipated for
the last five months of the fiscal year that have to do with the integrated
coordination center which is being created by the airport system
and they have requested our participation in that, but of course they will be reimbursing
us for it. So I'm going to skip to auto dealers and
you'll see a small decrease. But really that's just because
fiscal year 22 we saw uptick in the
increase of selling cars that have been stored and
the actual funding for that. So we tend to
budget pretty conservatively. So we've gone back to what
we typically would see during a year. And the last item
that I will include is the forensic transition. But I've already explained that one
why that's going down, so next slide please.
So this is the expenditure by fund. So for General Fund,
the proposed budget is $988,000,000
or a difference of 33 million.
And I will explain that a little bit later on
and go into a little bit more detail. In terms of the general budget for
police special Fund, we have a budget of $10.9
million and most of that is personnel. But we do also
have some increases because of technology increase,
technology enhancements that we are anticipating this fiscal year.
The only other thing that I will focus on is asset
forfeiture, but I think I've kind of mentioned that before and why that number
appears to be going up, but we didn't spend as much last year,
but we do anticipate spending a little bit more this year.
Thank you. Next slide please.
This is the expenditure highlights which shows the difference.
As I mentioned with General Fund there's a $33 million difference
which I'll go in into the next slide and I
believe I've already explained the differences in the others. So I'll move
forward with the next slide please. So this
is the slide that explains how we came
up to the 988,000,000. If you recall, last year
we had a budget adopted of 955,000,000 and
throughout the year there are adjustments to the budget.
For example, there are adjustments in the restricted funds
that are shared funds that we are provided
that number from the administration. And then we of
course we have the adjustment for the 3%
increase for the Hope budget is what I'd like to refer
to as the three three three that we're all very ecstatic to
see happen. And then we had a decrease in
our health benefit. So that's primarily because
we had a lot of more attrition than anticipated. So the
budget was adjusted to reflect that decrease for health
benefits. Then of course we have the Council council
support monies that we've received about $129,000 and
then that gets you and, and of course I can't, I would be remiss
if I didn't add on that. We added the
gunshot detection with the shot spotter and those
are two locations at 350 each. So that's the 700,000.
So that gets us down to what we refer to as the current budget.
And the current budget is just the adopted plus any adjustments we've made during the
year. And from there we get down to how we came
to the current budget, to the fiscal year budget.
And this pretty much shows you every item that
has been adjusted. A lot of it has to do with the Hope and
the contract with the police union HPU in
terms of the increases, the 4% and the 3%. And of course
we had an increase in the health care also.
So I'm not going to go through each one. I wanted to just highlight those
items that may bring up some question if you look
about halfway down there's, the Cadet adjustment.
So last year we had anticipated six classes, but we
now know that filling up the five classes is our priority.
So we readjusted that down to five classes
versus six classes. And then the
last several items here, it's called approved PBJs and
those are requests that we've made to adjust our budget.
And I'm happy to say that we had four this year. One had to do
with the body worn cameras, which was approved this last fiscal
year. And this 1.8 represents the
storage cost for the body worn cameras.
And of course, the Chief mentioned the ePRO program also.
Next slide, please.
So this slide represents the balance
between personnel cost and non personnel costs. So interesting enough,
we have 988,000,091% of
that pertains to personnel cost. Last year was about 92,
93%. And you may ask what's happened? Well,
we've got the ePROs program and we also have
another program, I can't remember the name, but the other program
which actually has added to the other
side of it. So now it's 91%. So it's going in the right
direction. Next slide, please.
So I'm going to move through these pretty quickly because if you see with
the special funds, it's mostly 50
50, mostly personnel and non personnel,
it's about 50 50. So with the Police special fund it is
52% for personnel and 48% for non
personnel and special funds. A lot of the personnel
has to do with overtime. There are some staff, but it's
primarily overtime cost that we receive fund
reimbursement for. Next slide please. So this is asset
forfeiture. It's the same case as 50 50
just about and that's personnel versus non personnel.
So next slide please. And this is the auto
dealers. The same with this one
in terms of personnel versus non personnel.
Next slide please. So we've put these two on
the same slide. The first one is a child safety and of course that's
strictly a flow through. So it's 100% or
almost 100% flow through for services
and for the forensic, it's 100% personnel.
Next slide, please. So this gives you a historical
factor in terms of how we have fared in comparison
with what we've spent versus our adopted budget. And as you
can see that we typically come on budget.
We spend a lot of time making sure that we stay within
our budget. We understand the budgets are tight and we are fiscally responsible
and we want to make sure that we stand here. So this actual
presentation shows that in a graphical manner.
Next slide. So the next few slides you'll see that
the adopted budget is much more than the expenditures.
A lot of times with the special funds, if we do not have
enough time to spend the money, it's just rolled over to the next fiscal
year and that's happened in the first five years of 2019
through 2023. Next slide please.
The same with asset forfeiture you'll see that same trend, but we
are working to make sure that the revenue and
the adopted budget and the expenditures are in
line, but there are some times when we run out of time.
Next slide, please. And this is the
auto dealers, which is typically on target.
Next slide, please. And of course it's the child safety
which is a smaller funds. Next slide.
So with that, I'm going to pass it back over to Chief if
he'd like to close us out. Just again, thanks for
the support of our council members and the citizens as
well. But we really wanted to kind of move through quickly because I wanted to
save time for questions and answers.
Thanks again, Ms. Jones. And Chief Finner.
It's not every day that we have the opportunity to have you
and your command staff in front of us. So again, I'd like to recognize Chief
Slinkert, chief Jones and Chief Satellite, and also
Ray Hunt and Doug Griffin with HPOU who are
valuable partners not only to the police department but to the city council as well.
And also Mr. Peter Stout with the CEO of the Houston
Forensic Science Lab. Our first question comes from council member Abby
Cayman. Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And I
have a list of questions, so just go ahead and put me back in queue.
Chief, first off, thank you so much for your leadership and to the entire
team all the way on down to each division as
we continue to face not only the
surgeon violent crime following the pandemic locally. But could
you share what you're seeing? I know you were just in DC,
what that trip was about and what we're seeing nationally and how
what we are doing is either working or not working.
Thank you for asking. It was a good trip for
not only me, but for the mayor and for our city and visiting
with the President, the Rescue
Act, he pledged to continue to
fund us, and that was a huge thing. But the meeting,
first of all, I just want to say honor to
those men and women who paid the ultimate sacrifice during
that weekend of memorial. But when
you're talking to other chiefs from around the nation,
you understand that everybody has the same problems,
with one exception. Nobody has the backlog problem that we
have here in Houston, Harris County. Absolutely nobody.
And in our conversations, they were amazed. But they're
dealing with some of the same other issues, the gun violence,
letting individuals out of jail when they're
repeating time and time, violent crime.
So that's the challenge. But also recruiting
and just hearing some of the things that they're doing. And I told the
mayor that I think I'll meet this Thursday. I want to talk to
him about some of the recruiting initiatives
that they are putting in place and also probably
using as more funding comes in, using some
of that for some incentives for individuals
coming in to the academy or actually recruiting
them. Mentioned recruitment.
There's been conversations and questions about cadet classes. And I
know you mentioned in this budget there's five, is that correct?
And could you clarify, though, because we oftentimes
talk about cadet classes, but we also are dealing with retention
issues. So can you share with us where that brings us in
terms of HPD?
Yes, staffing, the recruiting,
we can always improve. But the biggest problem right
now is the Attrition Rate We're Agent Agency and
a lot of these individuals who are leaving when they get 35,
30 years, it's hard to keep them
when they're ready to go. So as we put cadets in the
class on the back end, people are retiring. So that is a
huge challenge right now.
So it's very important that we just don't lose hope and understand
and hoping that that time itself out as some
of those retire and then other cadets
come through our academy and come on out on the streets.
Hopefully on the back end, in a few years, we'll be able to hold on
to a lot more for a longer time. It's not just
that we're adding additional numbers. We'll put you back in queue.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, Chief, for the presentation.
I have a question about investigative and special operations.
I know there was talk about clearance rates and how we were doing better ten
years ago than we were doing now.
And we added, I thought some classifieds
to that division. It looks like we budgeted for
more last year and then hired fewer, and now we're trying
to get more. Can you talk a little bit about yeah, I'm proud to say
that our clearance rate, divisional clearance rate and homicide
is at 80% now. That's great.
When you looked at last year in 2020,
those numbers were down. So we're trending in the right direction.
I want to give credit to the great investigative
work and also the leadership on the investigative side,
chief Jones and some of our other assistant chiefs and the men and
women who are doing just knockout investigations. But again,
people don't give enough credit to the value of
good relationships with citizens.
And you see time and time again, citizens are stepping up
more. And I think that's because of a better relationship and
more trust building in. So it has to
all gel together. But I'm excited about it, and I
just pray that we continue to trend that way. That's great news. Good to
hear. On the property room, how many classifieds
do we have working at the property room? I'm not sure on that number.
Does anybody have a property room? And if not, we'll get that to you.
Okay, that's great. And I'd like to see, in addition to the clearance rate
be put on the performance measures that you all include in the book,
the disposition of property. I know what we receive in and
what goes out. I think we're way in
more. We have way more in in all categories than
than what goes out. And that ties up a lot of officers. We include
that council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. Hello, Chief. It's good to see you doing this morning.
I'm well. So two questions. One's an aside from the general fund, I'm pretty
clear about how you're funded, but oftentimes we
receive grant where council approves grant award grant applications
rather to support the department. And I remember there was one
item, particularly that was almost like
a community mobile unit that
was the application was supposed to use
to do some community efforts. When do we receive information
that the award was actually accepted or funded and
that those capital pieces of equipment are actually within our hands?
That mobile brand? I think that got it's. Chief Johnson.
Commander Johnson. We just put in for a
year ago. Yeah. So we'll get some
follow up on that and see what we are, because it's a great idea.
We want to go to our communities because
of staffing. A lot of the storefronts were closed down.
So if we can have a mobile outreach,
I guess I used to call them Winnebagos vehicles,
but we can go directly to the community. Right. Just curious about
the status of that. And then secondly, I think my first year
in office, I took a tour of the forensic center. I was fascinated by it,
just overwhelmed with the amount of work that they do.
If I understand this, this is a decrease in their budget.
Is this the variance? Is that a variance? So for what we
have, it's just the number of individuals that transition over
from the city to the forensics. So it's just kind of like a holding
pattern because that was what was agreed upon in
order to keep them with the benefits of the sure. So then this
leads to my question in terms of making sure your officers
on the ground are doing yeoman's work around with the homicide rate.
Everyone's doing their part. That's the asset. We've asked the community
what type of funding would they need in order to make sure that evidence
is not backlog? All of that data collection so they can keep in
track with the goals that we're setting in the city. We have to stay in
communication with our forensic center as
we make more arrests. There is more of a demand
on them, and we need to make sure that we're meeting that demand.
So we've been in communication,
and I'm sure they're going to be in communication with the mayor to
make sure they get what they need. Sure. Wonderful. So you're
not saying we need to play the mega millions in order to get this
funded? Because maybe we need to play some. I think that there should be some
direct conversations on need
and we need to work together as a team. And the mayor
has been just stand up with that,
including the council. When any of us pertaining to
safety of our city needs something and we present it
to everybody has been very fair, and I want us
to keep doing that with all, not only HPD, but with all
departments in the city. Vice Mayor Pro TEM
martha Castex Tatum. Thank you, Chair. Chief Finner, thank you for the presentation.
Ms. Smith, thank you for always being so very thorough.
I wanted to talk a little bit about ShotSpotter.
We had almost a unanimous council vote on the support
of ShotSpotter. Our residents are clamoring
for ShotSpotter in our communities.
If you can give us some insight on the value of that and if you
anticipate that the cost of Shot spotter will decrease
I don't know about decreasing. We hope as we add more,
we can make better deals. But it's a
tremendous piece of technology, gun detection.
We've had cases where when
they discharge a firearm, we're immediately responding
to it and we have made some arrests. So as
many more as we can stand up as fund and allow.
But again, you look at different cities,
it's not just the city government responsibility.
Everybody has to kick in corporations so
we can stand up more, but it's something that's needed and wanted
by the chief and our men and women in uniform. So it's
something I hope we can find more. But also the
corporations and private entities step up and assist us
with. That. And then I wanted to talk about the
rollout of the outward facing cameras.
If we can eventually come back to maybe
public safety once that 90 day period is
up, to talk about those places that have installed
those cameras or the ones that have not. What we need to do to make
sure that we are enforcing that ordinance. One of the biggest complaints we
have in our district is the nuisance that
is created at a lot of those convenience stores. And when you let
that petty crime go on, it leads to bigger crime. So I think we
are headed in the right direction with those ordinances.
And we appreciate all that you and your entire team
is doing to keep us all safe in the city of Houston. Thank you.
Council Member we're very intentional on holding those convenience
stores, bars, and anybody, any,
established accountable for helping us fight
crime. Council member.
Leticia plummer. Thank you so much. Mayor Person. Thank you,
Chief. Good morning. Good morning. Two questions. What is
the retention rate of our cadets?
Do they stay with the force? Have we found that? You know,
I had some let me see if I had some numbers. When did they
graduate?
I forgot where I was on my page. I looked at it.
Be specific. When they graduate. Yes. Let me get you a percentage.
I know we have it somewhere here, but we'll get that to you.
Absolutely. Okay, wonderful. Thank you. I would like to know that you're looking at graduation
rate. How long? Stay on the course. Okay,
I got you. What's the retention rate of our graduates?
Because we're paying for them to be trained. Right. Got you. Okay. And then
what would that look like in terms of increasing that number, whatever that
is? We can talk offline on that. The other question is, you mentioned the
Biden administration. Congratulations on meeting with the President.
Thank you. Just honestly, I hear that we
can put thousands of officers on the ground, but if we don't get forensics funded
properly, it leads to two issues. Right. The backlog is
going to continue to increase, and then people are going to be falsely accused for
issues. Yes. So my question to you is maybe this is a not right now
question, but I would love to see our forensics department get the money that
they need. I think they need I think they're short, like, $9 million to
fill that, to get that backlog handled. And also
training and funding going
toward our officers that collect the data,
specimens, et cetera, on the ground so
we can make sure whatever is collected is collected properly. Yes.
And our officers are going to need training and all that they need to
do to that do that well. So those are two things I
would love to see line items for. Yes.
Okay. Thank you. Council Member Carolyn Evan
Shabaz. Thank you, Mayor Pro tim and I believe
last year, council Member Pollard gave 50,000,
I think, to the forensics unit. And I would like to,
like they say, follow that cab. I'd like to do that as well from
my council district service funds. And I urge other council
members to look at that as well, because we're
going to have to get these cases, get the information
that is given to us examined in order to
move through the court system. And so I would like to
say that and challenge my colleagues to do the same.
Thank you. Council member Tasha
Jackson. Thank you.
Hey, Chief. How are you? Good morning, Council. So I have three questions.
So what is HBB's clearance rate for violent crime
last year? And what is the clearance rate for
crime overall? And then lastly,
constituents have reached out about the cadet classes and just want
to know what is HBD doing to recruits
from within the neighborhoods? There's a complaint
that concern that the officers that's patrolling
the neighborhoods do not reflect the race,
the people that they're so they want to see more black officers
in the district. What are we doing to recruit
the black officer? Let me start with the clearance
rates. I went over the homicide. I'll have to get back with you,
and we'll get some time in the day. On the other clearance rates
for violent crimes. In terms of
pacifically African American officers,
the first thing I want to do is make sure that we're recruiting good officers.
I want to look at that heart. But I understand when you have
officers from the community who are committed, who knows
the community, it helps. So we
are doing everything we can to increase the
diversity in our agency. But I also do
not, and I say this with a lot of respect,
I don't ever want to discount the contributions
of non minority officers with our
agency. And I know that you're not accident or saying that, but I want to
acknowledge their work because they have been in our communities doing
all much work for 25,
35 years without any complaints and
retired honorably. So I do want to acknowledge
that. But at the same time, what are we doing to increase minorities?
We're going out to where they are, the universities.
Let me stop. Keep going. Okay,
universities. Some of the radio stations,
hip hop radio stations, wherever they
are, we instituted not
the word study, but the
life program. What is it, life history,
where you get an individual and I'll get this
quick example. We had at first,
you had to have so many college hours or you had to be honorably discharged
from the military. What about the young man and young lady that worked
at Ups or any other job for five years and
is a great individual? And we say in our agency,
well, you don't have a college, you don't have a military, we don't want you.
We did away with that. Okay? So we're looking at other ways
that we can recruit not only minorities, but anybody
to increase that pool. And we'll continue to do that. But I
need help from council members and everybody else in our
community. It's just not the job of the police department.
I need you all to advocate for us, and I know you all do,
but all citizens. It is a great career, and I know people
don't think that sometimes because they listen to the negative,
but this is an honorable profession, and we'll continue to do whatever we can
increase those numbers. All right,
so before we go to second round of questions from council members,
I have a couple of questions, and it's related to some of the comments
you made, specifically backlog and more demand on
the Houston Forensic Science Center.
Over the past couple of years, we've become very aware of a significant
backlog in forensic lab testing, mostly due
to COVID, mostly due to a halt in court operations,
increase in homicides. We have job openings that
we can't fill. What can we do?
Because it seems as though the testing that we're doing today won't
be available for three years. So to council Member Plummer's point and
to council member Evan Shabbaz's point, if we arrest someone
today for a homicide or whatever, do some testing,
it's not for three years that this person actually goes
to court. Thus we're seeing a lot of bad
people going back on the streets. So when people talk about
violence, I will point
to the courts, the judicial system in the city of Houston
and Harris County, but we also have to look at the Houston
Forensics Science Lab. So what
can we do to make sure that we get these bad
guys to trial quicker with forensic evidence and
get them off the streets? Merrick pro TEM.
I don't want to speak for them, but whatever we do,
we need to make sure that we're working together to
make sure that there's properly staffing
and funding of that. I don't know all the operations
over there, but just as we support the
police officers, we got to support all the departments,
and they need some help over there. And again,
I think the mayor, when it's bought to him and
laid out, he's going to make the right decision, and I'm sure
that city council will support it. So as
a non police guy, I'm going to draw a parallel between
forensic testing backlog and number
of criminals that are on the streets. So until we get
part a solved, we're going to constantly see more bad guys on the
streets. So I'll point to something. We gave you a million dollars
in ARPA funds for buyback guns. Has that program been successful?
How many guns have we bought back? And specifically, how many dollars have
we spent on that buyback program? We're still standing it up.
It was a lot dealing with it. You know,
right now we're running all of our guns through the
knob and system. So I want to do that.
But in a gun buyback program,
you can't get any identification from the people. What I understand,
but I still want to run those guns, so it's a
bit complicated, and I
got ms. Cloud is not here with our community affairs.
She's coordinating that with us. But we'll
do whatever we can with that. Okay. Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Chief.
I ask every department this, and I know that in the appendix,
you have a list here.
HPD is doing an extraordinary job with
very tough circumstances. The unmet needs
of the department. I'd like you to share a little bit about that.
Again, we have a certain amount in the budget.
There are constraints. What are the needs? I'm looking at
this list. A lot of it has to do with technology and
not in the list. I talk about it all the time. I'm like the broken
record about it. But CAD. RMS relies on CAD.
Real time crime center has to do with CAD. So all
of these can you talk about those costs, any additional needs,
including facility needs for
our divisions? Because those buildings
are like the rest of the city right now in terms of struggling. We're in
a city of a huge city. You look at our square miles.
The first need, we have an aging fleet.
If we get anything additional or extra money,
almost 50% of our fleet is past the lifespan,
and that's 100,005 years for marked 120,000
miles and seven years for unmarked. Almost 50% of
our vehicles are over. I was at the gas pumps before
I went to DC. And there was a young female officer,
and I had to apologize to her, and she drove up in that car
to put gas in there. I know we're doing the best that
we can do, but we have to do better.
As far as a real time crime center, we do
have through the Tag Center,
they have pledged to fund some of the
additions we need to make it a true
real time crime center. We're still waiting
for that money to come down. Hopefully they'll prove it and
we'll move forward on that.
But I would say, number one,
the need for better vehicles and
newer vehicles, that is a must. We're not in
a city that's very small and you can do
a lot of foot patrol. Even though I would love I love foot patrol.
I love neighborhood policing. But the fact of the matter is,
you move around in vehicles in Houston, and we need to keep up with
these criminals. And the only way we're going to be able to do that is
put money and funds as much as we can into the
fleet and really quickly.
In addition to Vice Mayor pro TEM's request on follow up on
the new camera ordinance, I'd love to get an update from
you all on the ATF partnership. We keep talking about
violent crime, but it's guns. Yes, it is.
We'll get it. Thank you. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. There was about a million for
increase in temporary personnel services in the Chiefs command.
Is that for a specific project or ePROs?
ePROs. That's what the okay,
got it. And then I just want to point out and you noticed you had
it in the adjustments. This was a $2 million over
budgeting of health benefits. That comes back to
the department. Correct. Like last year, there was
no so it was originally anticipated that
there would be more staffing and that
would actually adjust for the health benefits. And so the health
benefits was reduced by the finance. Got it. One more thing. And on
recruiting, I like the changes you made, the Ups
example and all. And also, you guys spent over a million dollars, which is
a really good thing. On tuition reimbursement, that should be another big recruiting
thing. Any kind of incentive. I really
want us to look at that as a team.
It's really important. But even front
end incentives. At the meeting
in DC, you asked about a councilwoman.
That's what I think has been working for other agencies,
and it may work for us, but also to
help with some of the debt. Now, the challenge is
when individuals come in and we give them front end incentives
and they leave, and we can say, well, hey, we require you to
stay three years or five years, but when they leave, who's collecting the
money? So then that's the challenge that some of the
other chiefs had as well. So just want to bring that up
so we have no other council members in queue. I'll ask the last questions.
It really upsets me when I turn on the media and I hear comments
like the murder capital of the world, and then your comment about homicides
moving from 70% to 70. I had some visitors in town
from my hometown of New Orleans, and they were talking about
crime, murder rates, things like that. And my explanation
was we have a significant problem with domestic
violence. The other day I read a report where a
lady approached a man with a gun. Man took it from her and shot
her. I don't know anyone in the world who
can stop something like that. Whether you have a police force
with 2 million people or a police force with one,
it seems to me like domestic violence shootings,
and I'll call them homicides, are happening each and every day.
So I think I understand your statistics on 70 to seven,
because every time I look at the TV, the murders
are related to domestic violence. So can you
lend a little color to that? As far as the homicide rate? Domestic violence
has ever anything we can domestic violence
is one category that's driving our homicide up.
But there has to be education. There has to be intervention and
intervention into it. And what I mean
by that, we have to make sure with our Dart program
and I'm so proud of that when we have an
advocate in the car with the police officer,
once you go to that scene and somebody is assaulted, they still
alive. It's a vicious cycle that's going to get worse.
If we can lend in what we do, those resources
to that victim or that complainant right away,
get them out of that situation,
that's the way that we save
lives. But it is frustrating to police officers when we're
judged. I don't know how you can prevent
it when it's behind walls, but we
can't forget about them. We have to do everything we can as a society to
make sure that we're addressing it. And we are, but it is frustrating.
It's also frustrating when people
turn and they push their own narrative.
What's the narrative now? How many people you talk and you hear
talking about the dramatic drop in
homicide rate? Okay, now we know summer is here
and we know what to expect during the summer. But we're rolling up
and we're going to meet the challenge. And I don't take all the credit for
homicides. I said we have some good investigators and good police
work, but it is truly something that this community
and everybody has to partner up with us to make the city safer.
But we're on the right track. And I thank you all again for all your
support. Thank you. Council member Abby Cayman,
I appreciate that you brought up domestic violence in chief. I'm going to assume that
the over $4 million in ARPA funds that are going towards
Dart, dart forensic nurses is helping.
And again, hats off to Dart. Some of the most dangerous
situations that they're responding to. But mayor pro TEM to your
point in terms of preventative action, again,
the majority of domestic violence homicides are with a firearm and
we have no red flag laws the courts aren't able even to
enforce right now. So if there's a record of someone perpetrating or
is a domestic abuser, I'm assuming,
chief, you all can't remove those firearms from that situation.
Yeah, we still can move when
there's evidence of violence, you can temporarily move those firearms
and we do do it, but I don't dab into
the politics too much. But I do want to say this lawmakers,
and we talked about this in DC. Around the nation, I don't
care if you're local, you state or you're federal,
everybody needs to be real careful as we move through
the pandemic and violent crimes. Be careful what you vote
for, be careful what you write in law, okay? When there's
a backlog, we need to do the best that we
can do and not point fingers at reducing the
guns on the street, especially in the wrong hands of individuals
who commit violence after violence. Now everybody's smart
in here and we read through the lines, but everybody needs to do their part.
I just encourage friends and family
and anybody. We need to do our part and be smart about gun
violence. We really do.
Council member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you.
Mayor Pro tim raised a really good point about the domestic violence,
but I can't help to think about active shooter issues
happening, and I know there was some in north Harris County. Buffalo is the
latest one. And so the investment in domestic
violence is significant. But when we're talking about active shooter and making
sure your division is ready because I have to have conversations with my father
about going to grocery stores right, and transitioning
that because of what could possibly be. We're a huge city and
I don't see that in terms of your division around active
shooter and that training. But do you need additional resources for your
men and women in order to always use additional resources?
Sure. Active shooting, anything else? But Councilwoman, you bring up
a valid point. We do need the world that
we're living in today. We all need to be ready for
whatever comes. And an active shooting is a problem,
and I hope I'm wrong,
but I think it's going to get worse before it gets better. And we
all have to look out for one another to the public. Be aware
of your surroundings. I want us to keep going where we're going and take care
of one another, but be aware of your surroundings.
We'll continue with our active shooting training that Steven
Daniels does and some other individuals,
and we need to increase that because you have to be in a mindset
and if you don't think about it before it happens,
you're going to freeze. So we got to get in the mindset
and we have to train our officers to respond quickly and effectively.
But also citizens need to know what to do.
The first few seconds of
an active shooter, the first few minutes,
if you can survive that, if you can do the right thing and
wait for the police arrive, once we arrive,
we handle it pretty quickly. So we all need to, as a community,
be aware of it and train up.
Vice mayor pro TEM martha kestex tatum. Thank you,
chair. I really wanted to just amplify some of
the performance measures that
you have in your book and the
external citizen complaints with the
expected performance measures of a reduction
of 2%. I like the
trend in that specific category,
especially because now we have more ways for people to report
their complaints. And the fact that we have opened
that up with the addition of Ms. Okafor's office
and the other opportunities that people have to
actually express their concerns and that we're trending downward,
I think it speaks volumes for our city and for
our police department. And then on the accomplishments
that we completed, 78 of 104
of the mayor's task Force on Policing Reform recommendations.
I don't think we tout that enough. When that was happening,
we had residents in the city of Houston asking for
these items and we completed 78 of
104 of those recommendations. And as
a city and a police department, I think this speaks
volumes for our residents to know that we hear them
and we want to make sure that we are serving them to the best of
our capabilities. And so I wanted to say thank you to all of
our HPD officers and everyone that served on that task
force, to the council members and to the entire city of
Houston, because public safety is one of the most important things
that will take place in our city. And I think we are
leading the nation, hence your visit to the
White House and setting a real standard as we
deal with tough issues in this country. Thank you so much
for bringing that up. That was in the talking points and I was trying to
save time, but I'm so proud of that and we are
all proud of that. I want to say this too,
right quick, if I can. When I was up
in DC. President Biden's
administration. Several members spoke of our one
Safe Houston plan. They said that it was one of the best that they
have seen because we're actually bringing people together and fighting crime,
violence, disruption programs, dealing with mental
illness, more funding for that, working with domestic violence.
But they were very excited about the way that we
are bringing people together, building trust,
working on issues that are symptoms
of violent crime. I'm really proud and
excited about it. And it's not a police thing, it's a community thing.
And that's huge here. And it starts with council,
it starts with our great mayor. And I
was very proud and I am proud about it. Thanks for allowing me to
say that. Thank you, Chief. And we have a number of public speakers
that are going to come before us in a minute. But before we
let you go back to the streets,
I applaud your decision. I'm not sure if who made it on the administrative
team, but to go from six cadet classes to five, but to
staff them with more individuals, to get them on the streets more
rapidly, I think that was a brilliant move and I'm glad to support it.
In the day of defunding police, I'm proud to say that
we add money to your budget, but we can reallocate the amount of money in
there to certain departments, like you mentioned, with the mental health component.
So a lot of those things that we're doing today are very creative
and I applaud you and your staff for doing those types of things.
The one thing that always bothers me, and this is my 9th
Police Department budget process, I always ask
this question, how many of your police officers are
retirement eligible today? Percentage wise?
Just a guess. About 27%?
27%. I look behind you and I see some great individuals and
I walk the streets every day. And you all
do a phenomenal job. I know I couldn't do it, so God
bless. Thank you for what you do. Stay safe.
And as I always say, whenever I say I'm the last guy,
it comes back to somebody else. So council member Robert Guy egos. I'll give you
the last word. Thank you, Mayor Protein. Thank you,
Chief, for the presentation. In regards to the budget,
in regards to recruiting, does HPD reach out to
the High School of Law Enforcement working some kind of
I know, like you stated, that right now you're required some college degree
or some college credits. Yes, and what have you.
So are you all partnering with the High School of Law Enforcement? Not only that
high school, other high schools. With our youth programs. I forgot
to mention that I'm glad you brought up youth programs and
I'm stepping outside, but it's very important youth
and going into this summer, please, whatever we do with Parks
and Rec, get those pools open, hire more lifeguards
and get some basketball goes up. So we have to do that.
To answer your question, absolutely. And that's a part of our
recruiting. With our Explorer program, we start working with those young
men and young women at a young age,
as early as the 9th grade, getting them acclimated and
hoping that they join our agency later.
Well, that's good to know. And I appreciate
also you mentioning regarding keeping
or us being aware of what's out there in regards to I
know what happened this past weekend in Buffalo and what happened in El
Paso a couple of years ago.
I know that we received calls from constituents.
A couple of weeks ago, there was a neo Nazi group that was putting baggies
out in people's driveways promoting
neo Nazism. And of course, we asked them to call
HPD. So I don't know if that's are you
getting other calls throughout the city as well?
We take those hate crimes and crimes of
bias really seriously. I hadn't seen the uptick,
but I'll get you some stats just to make sure. But it's
a call to our entire community to look after one another, and we really need
to stamp out that hate at the
earliest moment. We can just stop it
and stamp it out. And there's some responsibility to close
friends and family members as well. When you see it,
get your loved ones some help.
Great. Thank you. Once again,
thank you for what you do each and every day. Thank you
to my friends in HPOU and as I heard two weeks
ago, officers dismissed. We'll now go to
public speakers. Mayor Pro. Tim, before we leave,
I wanted to just reiterate that for the gun buyback program,
it's actually starting July 30, so I think that one was
just determined this morning. So I wanted to. Okay, so it doesn't start
until July. July. July. Got it. Thanks.
God bless. First public
speaker is Fabiola Jimenez.
Fabiola Jimenez. Going once, going twice.
Mr. Jason. Oliver.
Thank have handouts
today.
Sorry, I wasn't trying to put you to work, Councilmember Jackson. I wasn't expecting
everybody to run out during public comment.
And we're going to hold everybody to 1 minute, as instructions stated,
because we have a meeting that starts in just a little while and we have
to transition. All right, I'll go quick. So this
handout shows items that are consistently higher in general fund spending
than actuals and therefore good candidates free allocation to a department
like housing. I know council member Catholic Tatum is gone, but she mentioned
the complaint process. If you go on HPD's website right now,
please tell me if you see an easier process for filing a complaint.
It hasn't changed on their website. It still asks for your Social Security number
in a city like Houston. According to HPD stats and public
safety presentations, violent crime and crime overall was down year
to date before one Safe Houston was announced. I'm concerned that the public is being
misled about things like that. Also,
according to the Texas Sandra Bland Act racial profiling data
for 2021, HPD is a state leader in violent
traffic stops. We have only 3% of stops
in Texas, but 44% of violent stops statewide.
That averages out to five violent stops per day, with three of them
targeting black people each day. With these terrible statistics
and the clear danger posed both to officers and residents
by these hundreds of thousands of stops, how much are we paying
for this traffic enforcement? Thank you.
And I'm assuming this is referring to what I would call a
sort of a surplus. Look ahead. Exactly. Okay. Every year,
you'll notice within the Mo for monthly
financial reports, when we get to the end of the year, we have a
large differential between what we gave departments and what they've
actually spent. All that money rolls into our fund balance. That's why we
maintain a healthy fund balance. This year, it's projected to be 13
five based on exactly this information that you gave us.
So when the departments don't spend the money that's
been allocated by council, it rolls into fund balance, and we're at 13.5%,
and the obligated fund balance is 7.5%.
So we're doubling that for the rainy day. But we want departments
to spend that money. Right. So if we reallocate these
overages, right? Correct. We get hundreds of thousands, but millions
of dollars. Right. Then we get to use those monies for buyback programs or
forensic we heard the problem with forensic science lab. Maybe we use some
of that for parks or
parks, whatever. You're exactly right. Right. So I just want to say
that these are clear candidates for hundreds of thousands of dollars
of potential reallocation from years of consistent over budgeting for
these items. Council. Member Alcorn, some of the drainage improvements that
we talked about in District B. Absolutely. District e.
Stop. A blanding. Thank you. Question comes
from a robin. Sorry, I'm back in. Okay. I just wanted to point out,
I did ask I did notice that $1.4 million increase in temporary personnel
services, that is for hiring the retired officers. So that
looks like your biggest item on there. I think these are adjustments from
where we end up and where we're budgeting next year, correct? Yes,
sir. Ma'am. Thank you. Thank you. Mr. Oliver saba
blandy did bring your daughter today.
Listener I know she had tar testing. How many people
with a documented history of mental health challenges did HPD arrest
in 2000 and 22,021? How many calls received by emergency
dispatch regarding a mental health crisis were responded to with armed police officers
in 2000 and 22,021? How many of those were part of a Cert team?
How many of those were individual officers without the support of a trained mental
health professional? How many calls received by emergency dispatch
regarding a mental health crises were responded to with an unarmed
response through MCOT in 2000 and 22,021? I heard
it would only cost 23 million to expand Heart Holistic Assistance Response
Team to cover all of Harris County. Harris county currently has invested
1.2 million for a pilot program. How would it relieve HPD officers
to have such a program expanded into Houston? Would the city of Houston consider
expanding the Heart pilot into Houston? To quote precinct to
Commissioner Adrian Garcia, heart is a historic investment in
public safety, and I'm excited to see this cutting edge program be launched soon.
As a longtime member of law enforcement who has seen firsthand what's
happening in some communities, I know that having the right people respond to
a scene can make all the difference between a positive or tragic outcome. Okay,
thank you for your comments. What I would do is I would send that exact
list and give it to your council member, and let's make sure that we
have that answered, and we'll post that on SharePoint for every council member.
So thank you for your interest. Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. And thank you to the public speakers. I think this is hard.
You've sat through a long meeting, and you're really trying to spit it all out.
I will have a form up on my website, hopefully by the end of the
day. I send it out via email where you can submit questions
easily. We want to make sure we track all that too fast to write down.
But thank you very much for your participation, and we do respect
the fact that you have questions that you want answered. Thank you.
And thank you for that notice. And also have council
members questions that were asked during this session and other sessions posted
to SharePoint as well. And we'll make sure that we get those included for the
public mr. Christopher Rivera.
Hello, Nick. I'm glad
some council members mentioned the performance measures measurements.
My question is, why should the police department receive an additional $32 million when
they continue to fail and in some instances barely meet the department's
2022 performance measurement goals? For example, the police
set a response time goal of 75%. The police estimate
they will only reach that goal by 55% this year,
failing to meet that goal by 20% next year, the police
will be lowering that goal to 65% to accommodate the police slow response.
Here's an instance when police barely reached their goal. The police department
priority was to have an average response time of four to six minutes.
The police estimate that the average response time is five minutes and 54 seconds.
The previous year's response time was slightly faster. Why should
we continue invest in systems that fail us when there is so much need for
housing, parks and services that benefit the community and
doesn't criminalize us? I would like a response.
Thank you, Mr. Rivera. No response. There are
no council members in queue.
Lauren Johnson,
am I closing us out today?
So just to be fair,
I heard you saying that we should submit our questions to the
council, and we'll do that, but also we
couldn't have done that before because the presentations hadn't been made.
I know the slides were available, but also the process has been different
in previous days, so that wasn't possible.
I was interested in hearing about the site and release program.
I'd like to know a little more about how many times that has been
used in 2000 and 22,021,
and also if there are plans
to expand it and find out where the problems exist
in that program. Because I think it should be
being used more and we haven't been seeing it live up to its full potential.
So I think it's important to identify what's going on with that and how
we can improve that program. That's it.
Thank you, Ms. Johnson. Thanks, Mr Peter Stout.
Good afternoon, you all. Dr. Peter Stout, head nerd of the crime lab.
I mostly showed up just to answer any questions. I figured
there probably would be some questions with HPD as we
are inextricably linked to what HPD does. They depend on
our results for their investigative investigations.
The courts depend on our results for prosecutions.
And if there are questions I can answer for you now about where
we're at, I know there was one question, I forget who asked
it, about pages 456 and 457
are fund 20 213. That was the transitionary
fund for the LGC when we started as the LGC. So right now
it's got three employees left in it. That's why
that is only about 300,000. If you look for the rest of what our budget
is, is on page 233. There's one note in there of the 28
and a half million, and that is really the discussion of the difference between that
and what my board passed and the differences of what
that will mean for us, of what we can do in the coming couple of
years. But if there are questions, I'm happy. Yes. Council member. Leticia plummer.
Thank you so much. And thank you, Dr. Staff, for everything that you do with
your whole entire team. Can you explain a little bit? I know there's a
tell me exactly how much you're looking to need
in terms of increase of your budget and then just a very quick synopsis of
what those those are going to be used for. Certainly what my board passed was
34.4 million.
That includes 2.6 million for wage adjustments.
We are getting our heads handed to us in retention and recruiting.
There's about a million in there to expand the crime scene
unit. There is about
500,000 in there. And we basically walk down the
places that we are the most concerned. Crime scene firearms next.
After that is toxicology Layton prints.
And the balance of that, this is about a $5.9 million
difference from this year's budget into next year.
So it's between staffing and then trying to stabilize
the growth of the backlogs that we're seeing.
Another question, and if you receive that money, do you believe that
we could decrease the backlog that we have currently? I don't
think so. Okay. And this is part of the concern that I have.
We have had backlogs grow somewhere between twice
to about five fold, depending on which discipline you're looking at. The difficulty
for us is we are disproportionately affected by homicide in particular,
creates a lot of evidence. The evidence that it creates goes to our most
expensive disciplines. So it's really disproportionate in the impact
that it has on the laboratory.
It is very long arc for us, training examiners
finding equipment. So really, if I were to try
and eliminate the backlog, that would probably take something more in the neighborhood
of 45 million. Even if that number were realistic,
I couldn't spend it. I can't find the people, I can't find the equipment in
this next year. So the 34 is designed to work with
what we've got and try and stabilize the growth of the backlogs.
We have 200 amazing people.
I have full confidence they will probably exceed expectations.
But so that you have an understanding of the expectations of what that's designed for,
it is to stabilize backlogs, not reduce anything.
Council member Abbey Cayman. Thank you,
Dr Stout. Just so we're clear, when we talk about evidence backlogs,
that's distinct from the current court backlog.
Correct. Do you want to expand upon that a little bit? Oh, boy.
Yeah. So a crime laboratory gets to be sandwiched
between law enforcement doing investigations and
we do evidence processing as part of investigations.
And as law enforcement builds a case, then law enforcement
hands that case over to prosecutors to develop
the case for prosecution. At that point, there is a whole nother
suite of requests we often get that come from prosecution.
So for us, we've got the increase in particularly
homicide over the last couple of years that sandwiched us from that side
now with the absolutely mind boggling backlog
in the courts as that is picking back up the pressure
from that to support past results that we've done in
court goes up. And the request from prosecutors who are now starting to
deal with cases goes up. So right now my folks are testifying on
violent crime cases typically from about 2017, 2018 as
the courts catch up to where we're at. This is part of my concern is
somewhere in about the next six to twelve months we start to become the backlog
and the bottleneck because the courts are then going to start waiting on us for
results on cases when they get there. Right now we're not just
to be clear as it stands today, and I appreciate it always helps
right when we have people saying, hey, in about six months or a year we're
going to have a challenge and we need to be looking at that now.
So I appreciate that very much. And right now
the court backlog is not hinging
on the incredible work that the Forensic Science Center is
doing. The DA's office is not hinged on
that either. No, that's not where at right now.
You can see the arc of this. I joke
explaining our work is a little bit more like explaining orbital dynamics than it
is like driving a car. Because what we do now for us impacts
where we're at in about two years. And my concern is even if
you back the truckload of money over on me in two years,
I can't do much with it for another two years. Understood,
but I really appreciate the clarification. Thank you.
So a follow up. So your backlog is related
to people and equipment. Correct. Okay. So you have a homicide today
looking at a presentation that you had given ways back.
We won't get to the evidence because of the backlog that we
have for three years. And if
that employee who's doing the evidence collection and the data leaves,
the clock starts over again. So that employee goes back to day
one and that three years was wasted.
Yeah. This is a consistent problem for us and really for every
laboratory in the state as we have employees that leave and
this is part of the cost to me for employees, we figure.
And I was just at the meeting of American Society Crime Laboratory directors
a couple of weeks ago. Most labs, it's somewhere between 300,000
and $500,000 to train a new analyst just
out of the box, somewhere between about a year to three years before
they're productive in the laboratory. If they leave in
the court, unless we can get that person to come back
and testify about that, the evidence becomes hearsay. So most
prosecutors will want and pressure us to rework
the case with somebody that's actually currently employed. So you can almost take when
an employee leaves, you can take the work that they've done for about the last
three to five years and throw it out the way backlog. Absolutely.
So what's the solution? We have to stay
ahead of the curve. And this is why,
to Council Member Cayman's point right now, we're not the
problem. I am desperately trying to not be the problem about
two years from now, because we have to try and stay ahead of the arc
of this, knowing all of these challenges that we have to get equipment in
to validate things to train employees so
that two years from now, we aren't the headline.
So I would invite Chair Cayman to
bring this up in one of your public safety. Because when I started reviewing
the material for today's presentation, I went back and looked at
the position that if somebody leaves, then you start the clock all
over again, and you just wasted three years. And that person sits in jail for
six years instead of three until the trial comes. So I'd
love to dig into this a little bit more when we have more time.
Those conversations and the planning for that we're speaking,
those are conversations that we're currently having right now. Okay, great.
Thank you. No other council members in queue. Thank you, Doctor. Thank you
very much. I appreciate your support. Yes. Thanks, Dr. Sal. Appreciate what you do.
Joe Grochell followed
by Melissa Martinez and Aris Brown.
So we are spending $8 million on community affairs.
This seems like a very expensive duplication of city services,
especially neighborhoods, which could be
beneficial for all the other departments we've been hearing from.
Would council members consider and support consolidation?
And then my other question is in
what the police said in his objectives is how
do you measure reduce fear?
I would like him to like you all to figure that out. How do you
measure reduce fear? If you
write those questions I'm sure you have in your notes, submit it to your
council member. We will enter that and we will get the answers within 48 hours.
Thank you, and thanks again for coming. You're welcome. Melissa Martinez.
Hi. I have a couple
of questions, such as how many unhoused students and how
many the in house and students have been
arrested by HPD in 2000 and 22,021?
Because I know that a lot of council members have previously discussed
about all these cases of domestic abuse
and all these other abusive, very violent
situations. And I wanted to follow up with another question,
because after listening to other departments that were brought up here today
on how some, even you yourself,
praise how much they could do while being underfunded
within their own limited, low budgets. And I wanted to ask
if there could be a possibility with all these issues of
being at the intersections and facing these violences that
they do need to be funded, such as housing in
public libraries, the public recreations.
As myself,
I am a survivor of domestic abuse. And those are those things yes,
ma'am. That helped me. Yes, ma'am. So it comes down to
it's an easy equation. It's revenue versus
expenses. Revenue is capped.
We receive revenue from basically two sources property
taxes and sales taxes. Our sales tax
projections look pretty good. Unfortunately, with inflation taking
place, the cost of goods are going up. Thus our sales tax
revenue has gone up. This will be the 8th year out of
the past nine years that we've had a tax rate
decrease. And the tax rate is a function well,
your taxes on your homestead is a
function of two variables. The tax rate that we
have times your value of your home. That's the revenue
we receive on the property tax.
So we're capped by the state of Texas so that every year
we have to reduce our tax rate, which means we
don't get the ability to spend the money that
is coming in via property taxes because it is capped,
as is every major city in the state of Texas.
However, the cap we're under is different
than the cap. Dallas is under, san Antonio is
under, and Austin is under because they're on a lesser cap.
So when you look at property taxes, the tax rate
has gone down eight of the last nine years. When you look
at sales tax revenue, we've had some tough times during COVID
but the projections look better. At the same time,
our personnel costs are increasing. Police 4%
salary increase come July 1 fire 6%
salary increase come July 1 city Employees
and municipal Employees 3% July
1 and you saw in the information we were presented that 65%
of our overall budget on the expense side is due to personnel.
So when you have those equations, it's a no win situation
unless you go out and tell people in the city of Houston, do you
want your taxes to increase?
Every year I do this and I announce it to fellow council members.
I look at my tax bill and I share it publicly.
And in my tax bill this year that I paid in February,
the amount of dollars that I gave to the city of Houston was
19% of my overall tax bill.
My school district taxes are 56%.
We had an election on Saturday for a bond referendum
that passed overwhelmingly. But yet, every time
I'm out in public, people look at me and say, your taxes are way
too high in the city of Houston. And I point back to my school
district taxes. Yeah, you get what you pay for.
But I have no children anymore that are in
the K through twelve education and I look really closely at the dollars
that are spent in my particular school district. So I've rambled way too
much. But we have a no win situation in the
city of Houston because of the property tax cap that we're under
and the sales tax revenue projections that we see coming at us.
Because basically, we have those two sources. And if I ask Joe Q
public if they want their taxes increased by the city, they'll say, not no,
but heck no. Thank you. I wanted
to follow up real quick because we got to get out about all these
caps on the taxes. And I was asking that's why I was
directing it towards HBD, having all these allocations
of funds, and that way that other departments
could be invested through those instead of just
hiring these tax caps that you were mentioning.
Yes. Thank you,
Eris Brown. Last but not least
for the day.
Hello, city Council. I just want to say it's particularly heartbreaking
to sit and a lot of people have come from their
jobs and are not able to receive income
because they're here, and not to be able to have their questions answered by the
folks who make the presentations. And so I did want to mention
that my first question is research
has shown strategically and well designed parks
can reduce gun violence, improve safety, and keep residents healthier
with the council see a benefit in allocating some of the resources to
the very clearly underfunded Parks and Recreation Department.
But what would alleviate the work that needs to be done by HPD officers?
We've been talking a lot about prevention,
and a lot of the measures that we've thought about with HPD's presentation
have been reactive. Adding more, doing this. Are we interested in
more preventative measures by funding through parks and recreation
libraries, et cetera? My first question, my second question
is the PFM report.
And Chief Finner's comments last year showed that we've had police
officers doing the work that can and should be done by civilians.
I wanted to know if there has been a shift in that practice at all.
If you go to the website, HPD has about 5400 officers
and 892 civilians. I'm interested
if we've made any sort of shifts in those past couple of years.
Thank you for your question. If you look at personnel,
classified versus civilian,
classified was 93%, civilian was 7%
in the 2023 budget. And then the personnel
on we'll get back with you. There's a number of different
categories with that. So if you would post your question to
your council member, we'll make sure that question
is answered. Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you, Mayor Pro
TEM. And thank you to all the speakers who spent time coming in person
to address your question. One I would like to see the study so I can
see what you're reading. So if you want to send that to our offices,
that would be great. I think there's always ways
in which we can look at preventative measures through either different
programs, after school programs, parks, libraries,
and it would be great if we could have some additional dollars for those
programs. I think from parks,
libraries, airports, police, fire,
they're all going to say, we need more. There's not one department
that's going to say we couldn't perform
better if we had more dollars. And so from our standpoint,
we have to make reasonable decisions
regarding where those allocations are. Every single
night you turn on the news, all you hear is issues with public safety.
That is the number one email we get. That is the number one call
we get. Whenever we go to
homeowners associations, people are talking about crime. They're also talking about trash.
They're also talking about a couple of other things, but they're always talking about crime.
So we have to find ways in which to provide
adequate law enforcement and public safety, but also kind of
reimagine it that it's not always in the same way.
So to think about police officers not
always having to serve in traditional roles, I think Council Member Leticia
Plummer, she brought forth an amendment last year regarding having
more clinicians and technicians and medical professionals. And that's something
that the mayor has put forth in his One Safe Houston
plan. So we are looking at ways in which to not have the
same type of traditional police officers do, the same type of traditional
duties, but it's something that we need to continue to explore to see how we
can make those additional steps. Right. And thanks
for Ms. Brown, for your comments. As we talked about in their session,
we've increased the budget projected to increase the budget in police.
But the way we allocate those dollars are a lot different this year
moving forward versus last year piggybacking police with
mental health problems, the homeless initiative that we have a big
situation with. So to Council Member Pollard's point,
using the dollars a little bit differently moving forward
than we do today, we don't think reimagination. I'm interested
in how we can imagine these things outside of the methods that haven't worked,
like the police department and actually putting them in programs that can work
if we're thinking about reimagination, right? Yes, ma'am. I think that'd
be a difference of opinion and perspective on what
may work and what does not work. And I think those are discussions we need
to continue to have. Absolutely. And I appreciate you making
those comments. And if you could provide the information on that study, I'd love to
read it. Absolutely. Thank you. You're welcome. Yes, ma'am. Thank you. There are no other
public speaking meeting adjourned until tomorrow. We'll pick up budget meetings at
01:00 with Houston Airport System.